da
[Müzik]
tekrar merhabalar tedex Ailesi Kraker
gibi
ben neredeyse kadrolu eleman gibi
çalışıyorum artık ama çok keyif alıyorum
çünkü gençlerle birlikte olmak ayrı bir
dinamizm ayrı bir güzellik veriyor o
bağlamda bu zor günler geçiren
insanoğlunun her ne şartlarda olursa
olsun bir şekilde diğer insanlara
dokunabilmek için ddx ki benim Bey
Mahallesi'nin bulmuş olduğumu çözüm de
oldukça şık oldukça güzel bir şey
özelliklerine teşekkür ediyorum
Edison ampulü bulduğu zaman
bazıları sevinmişti bazıları da çok
üzülmüştü üzülen lerden biri
Mumcular the Çünkü Mumcular ampul
bulunca bu teknoloji keşfedilince bu
işlerini kaybettiler ve Bu bağlamda da
edisondan hiç hoşlanmadı lar yine this
Ondan hoşlanmayan bir kişi vardı Tesla
onun problemi kişisel bir problemdi ama
teknolojiyle çok problemleri yoktu ikisi
Aynı kafada üstüne biliyorlardı bugün
Edison'un ampulü bulduğunda sevinen bir
kesin daha vardı Balinalar Çünkü bu
teknoloji onların hayatta kalmasını
sağlayan bir teknoloji diod Fakat bugün
Hayatımızın her noktasına gelen bu
teknoloji ve hayatımızı değiştiren bu
teknoloji dedi sana borçluyuz
Bununla birlikte belki çok önemli bir
teknolojik buluş gibi görünmese bile ama
hayatımızı değiştiren çok basit bir
buluş yapılmıştı bir teknoloji
geliştirilmiştir kibrit teknolojisi tabi
kirli teknolojisi bulunduğu zaman
İnsanlardan bazıları buna sevinmişti ama
üzülenler de kavak ağaçları olmuştu
Çünkü tipik yapabilmek için Kavak
ağaçlarında ihtiyaç E
tabii ki bitkiler bu işi yaparken Kavak
ağaçlarını tüketiyorlar the fakat bir
şey daha yapıyorlardı
sanayide kullandıkları işçilerin hemen
hemen çoğunda o dönem kullanılan
teknolojiden dolayı hepsi çenelerini
kaybetmeye başlamıştı çene kanseri diye
bir kanser ortaya çıkmıştı bu Fakat ne
zaman ki kibrit teknoloji değişmeye
başladı ve özellikle piyasaya bu
bildiğimiz takar Çakmaklar çıkmaya
başlayınca da tipik teknolojiden
kurtulmaya başladık Tabi bunu da bu
teknolojik değişmedeki piçler çok
hoşlanmadı ama şu an her yerde
gördüğünüz bu çakmakları kullanarak
Kavak ağaçlarını kurtarmaya çalışıyoruz
ve ne mutlu ki ne mutlu ki
ülkedeki bizim ülkemizde kimlik üreten
fabrika sayısı çok çok azaldı yani
ağaçlar Bu sayede biraz daha fazla
yaşama şansını yakalamış oldular
bu
Napolyon dünyada kabul edilen büyük
asker dağlarından biridir Hatta Mustafa
Kemal Atatürk'e de sorduklarında
Napolyon'un nasıl bilirsin diyerekten O
da demiştir ki onu tarih yazdırılacak
bugün Napolyon topraktan kalkıp aramıza
gelsene ona sorsak bu savaşı
kazanabilmek için Çünkü Rus savaşından
sonra Napolyon iktidarını kaybetmişti
desek diyordu Hangi teknoloji bugün
istersin bize diyeceği teknoloji şuydu
konserve teknolojisini bana verin
Rusya'yı alayım diyecektim çünkü onun
olduğu dönemde olduğunu biliyordu ki
Ordu midesi üzerinde yürüyordu ve o
Lojistik Deha olarak kabul edilen
Napolyon ordusunu beslenemediği için
daha Rusya'ya giderken Moskova
Yollarında darmadağın olmuştu geldiğinde
zaten iktidarını kaybetti ve hapishaneye
düştüm bazı teknolojiler vardır ki o
kadar küçüktür ama hayatımıza öyle
dokunuşlar yapar ki hem devletleri bu
hem de toplumların tarihinde müthiş bir
devrim sağlar
yine bir teknoloji vardır ki bazen
ölümdür bu teknoloji Ama bazen de size
barışı getirir bolluğu getir mesela ve
yeşil devrim' diye bugün bildiğimiz ve
karnımızın doymasını
Borçlu olduğumuz bir teknoloji var gübre
teknolojisi sentetik gübre teknoloji
Bugün ne kadarda eleştirecek yapsak da
her tür televizyon kanallarında onu
Yerden Yere Vur Sakla bu Teknoloji
olmasaydı şu an önümüze açtık ki bu
teknoloji Yüzyıl önce vuruldu mu bu
teknoloji bulunurken de şu yapıldı bir
dünya savaşı bitmişti dinamit
fabrikaların hepsi boş kalmıştı Çünkü
savaş yoktu ortada o zaman dediler ki
bir akıllı çıktı bir teknoloji
geliştirdi ya dedi ki bu dinamit
fabrikalarında Ben sentetik gübre
üretebilirim dedi Bu defa o savaş
wakanda o Fabrikalar bir anda bolluk ve
Gıda üreten fabrikalara verilmiştir yani
teknoloji yine müzik kurtardım
bu ve insanlık tarihine baktığımızda o
kadar çok teknolojik ortaya çıkarttık ki
bunlar bazıları çok basit Tamam
hayatımızı değiştiren teknolojilerde
biri tekerlek tir biri ateşli biri
barutlu biri matbaayı biri yazı
teknolojisi ydi ama bir teknoloji ortaya
çıktı ki Bugünlerimize altüst eden bir
teknoloji oldu acayip bir devrim oldu
buna da buhar makineleri teknolojisi
bugün fatura elektrik faturaları geldiği
zaman hepiniz yaptırırsınız Ya bu nasıl
bir fatura Bu faturayı kim ödeyecek diye
ve birimi okuduğunuzda birimin sonunda
kilovat diye yazar bir kilometre bulan
kişi yani James Watt kendi makinesi olan
Buhar makinesine tarif edebilmesi için
bu birimi verdi onu buldu o makinelerden
çok para kazandı biz hala onu bulmuş
olduğu birimin karşılığında bir fatura
veriyor ve Ne makinesi bulunduktan sonra
başka başka yeni şeyler de çıktı
elektrik bulunduğu Petrol bulunduğu ve
bu gün geldiğimiz dünyada dijitalizm
diye bir şey çıktı şu an bütün kurumlar
dijital izin propagandası yapıyor ama
bunu bize söylerken dijitalleşme ile
birlikte söylüyor Onun için şu an
aslında insanlık olarak bir ince bir
çizgide Yürüyoruz israt Köprüsü'nden
geçiyoruz
janjanlı bir ambalajı sarılmış bir
dijitalleşmenin perde arkasında yaşanan
bir dijitalizm olduğunu Büyük ihtimal 20
yıl sonra evimiz anlayacağız Şimdi niye
alacağımızı size anlatayım
teknoloji öyle birşeydir ki size ne
kadar ödemeniz gerektiğini de söyler
yani Kaç çocuğunuz olsun 10 tane mi Bir
tane mi iki tane su Bunu siz karar
veremezsiniz teknoloji karar verir ve
teknolojide karar vermişti dahaki
insanlık 1700 yılına gelene kadar
dünyanın nüfusu aşağı bu 300 milyon
civarı ydı ki eski atalarımızın nüfusu
15 milyon yani İstanbul'un nüfusundan
daha az bir nüfus 1/700 yılına
geldiğimizde Biraz önceki James Watt
buhar makinesini buluncaya üretim bir
anda bollaştı ve bulaşınca insan gücüne
ihtiyaç duyuldu Öğretim bulaştı bir de
tüketici lazım E o zaman dendi ki hadi
yürüyelim w1700 yılından bugüne gelene
kadar milyar bile herkes büyüdük o kadar
kalabalıklaştıkça bugün geldiğimiz rakam
7 milyar bir Ve bundan sonrası için yeni
öngörüler ortaya çıkmaya başladı ve ilk
kez iki ay önce Birleşmiş Milletler dedi
ki gelecekte insan nüfusu atmayacak
çünkü dedi teknoloji insan nüfusunun
artmasını Artık istemiyor Çünkü artık
insan gücüne ihtiyacım yok Sanayi Öyle
bir hale dönüşüyor ki ki Sanayi 4 0'la
bu gerçekleşiyor artık fabrikada
çalışacak bu ihtiyacımız yok Sadece
belli bir asgari ücretle insanlara para
verip evinde besleyebileceğimiz bir
kitle yaratılmak üzere yeni bir kurgu
ortaya çıkıyor yani teknoloji öyle bir
şey ki size ne zaman ne yapacağınız da
söylüyor bu ülkeler bazen teknolojiye
savunma içinde ihtiyaç duyarlar Ordu
kurmak için size adam lazımdır onun
içinde ne kadar çok bireyiz varsa o
kadar güçlü orduları bir araya
getirebilirsiniz ama bugün olmaz artık
ihtiyacımız kalmadı çünkü robot
teknolojisi öyle bir hızlı gelişiyor ki
artık insandan bir asker yaratmaya gerek
yok bugün iha'lar siyahlar insansız
uçaklar insansız tanklar insansız
araçlar her tarafı kaplamaya başladı ve
savunma sanayinin de artık insana
ihtiyacı olmadığından sonra dolayı
teknoloji bize şunu söyleyecek kardeşim
Yeter artık üreme yine
bu ve teknoloji şuna karar verdi insanın
yerini alabilecek yeni makineler
yaratıyor Bunlardan en büyüğünü zaten
ekranda gördüğünüz firma geliştirdi
köpekler yaptı Burada gördüğünüz gibi
robotlar yaptı Artık hem savaşta hem
barışta hem fabrikada hem ev
hizmetlerinde Ya bizimle birlikte
yaşayabilecek ve bunun ötesinde insanın
görevini alabilecek yeni yeni robotlar
yeni yeni teknikler ortaya çıktı
Eğer bu videoyu iki yıl önce
öğrencilerime gösterirken Antepli iki
tane kız öğrencim
BİM yan yana otururken aralarında
Konuşmaya başladılar dedim Ne
konuşuyorsunuz Hocam dedi bunu dedi Her
gelirse dedi Biz evde kalırız dedim ya
dünkü Bu sizin çeyizlik malzemeleri
bundan korkmayın artık bundan sonra
çeyiz olarak böyle bir cihaz alacaksınız
başka bir şeye ihtiyacınız yok ve en
güzeli dedim evde kalmayacaksınız bu
makine sizin kaynanasının yapacağı en
iyi lezzetli yemekleri Eşinize sunmanızı
sağlayacak sadece bunu reçete
gireceksiniz bazen Reçeteye de girmenize
gerek yok bu cihaz zaten kaynanayı
seyrederken O yemek vereceksin de kendi
kendine öğrenip hazırlanmış olacak dedim
Bundan korkmayın bu çeyizlik malzeme Siz
iki slayt sonra göstereceğim cihazdan
korktun O zaman siz Evde kalacaksın Peki
tek bu nereye doğru itekliyor
bu yapılan bir araştırma şunu gösteriyor
Artık insanlar evde yemek yapmak yapmak
istemiyor ilk kez beş yıllık ya dünyada
evde tüketilen yemek miktarıyla dışarıda
tüketilen yemek miktarı işlendi bu şu
demek insanlar artık küçük mutfaklarda
hazır ve Yar Az önceki robotun
hazırlamış olduğu yemekleri yemek
istiyor teknoloji bizi bir yere doğru
hiç bekliyor ve öyle biri tekleme
yapıyor ki bundan sonra üzerinde
düşündüğümüz teknoloji şöyle bir şey
yukarıda bir Yapay Zeka da altında bir
bulut sistemi Siz sabah evden çıkarken
size takılmış olan bir çift ya da
kolunuzdaki şu an hala Çorlu kullanmış
olduğu akıllı saat Sürekli sizin
vücudunuzdan bilgi alıp Buluta
gönderecek Bulut bu bilgiyi yapay zekaya
gönderecek Yapay Zeka diyecek ki ha
bugün Mustafa bak kalktı vücut bu
metabolizmasının durumu şu A vitamini
fazla C vitamini eksik ve bugünkü
takvimine göre bu adam spor yapacak veya
şu şu toplantılara girecek o zaman buna
bilmeni hazırlayın diyecek Siz günlük
hayatınıza devam ederken Yapay Zeka
Bulut vasıtasıyla sizin haberiniz
olmadan evdeki Buzdolabını kontrol
edecek evdeki robot larınızı kontrol
edecek Biraz önce gördüğünüz robota şunu
söyleyecek Bugün Mustafa'nın orta
düzeyde bir performansı var akşam o
geldiği zaman ona bir kuru fasulye yap
ama kalorisi çok yüksek olmasın çünkü
bugün orta düzeyde bir yaşam yaptı ve
buzdolabına diyecek ki toplarını kontrol
et ve marketten de sipariş ver Çünkü
yumurta sayısı azalmış olabilir öyle bir
dünya şu an kuruluyor ve özellikle de bu
teknoloji akademisyenler o kadar çok
geliştirmeye başladılar ki yakın zamanda
hayat bizi bir çok ilginç bir noktaya
doğru it eklemiş oldu
Biraz önce söylediğim iki öğrencimin
evde kalmasına sebep olacak teknoloji
bul Çünkü Japonya'da hem erkekler hem de
kızlar artık evlen diyor bu tek yaşama
oranı yüzde kırklara doğru gitmeye
başladı gençler arasında Çünkü yapılan
araştırmalar şunu söylüyor Yeniçağ daha
yeni düzende insanlar gençler bir
insanla ömür boyu getirmek istemiyor
onun derdini çekmek istemiyor Onlar her
gün aynı sohbeti yapmak istemiyor hayat
şartları çok maliyetli olduğu için o
sorumluluğu almak istemiyor ya bir de
çocuk oldu Hadi bunu da istikbalini
düşüneyim gibi bir dertle çekmek
istemiyorum onun için de Japonya'da
insanlar artık gençler özellikle bir
tabletle evleniyor veya tablet de
Evlenmiyor Sabile bir tabletle evinde
Hayat geçiriyor ondan sohbet ediyor O
biraz teknoloji ve gelişti hologram
larla uğraşmaya başlıyor ve bu yeni
yaşam tarzı Aslında aile yapılarını da
Japonya gibi ülkelerde değiştir diye
başladı bu yavaş yavaş Büyük ihtimal bu
taraflara doğru gelecek bu ne demek
evlilik mi yasasının artık değişmesi
veya ortadan kalkması demek evlilik
Müessesesi kalkarsa nüfusa da ihtiyaç
yok demek zaten gelişen dünyada değişen
teknoloji ile çok fazla insana da
ihtiyaç yok ya Bu ne demek Yeni Bir
Dünya düzeninin de yavaş yavaş teknoloji
ile birlikte önümüze doğru geldiğini
gösterir asıl Teknolojinin hayatımıza
dokunacağını şey bu bu Nero
o
link Elmas yeni bölümü geliştirdi bu
bambaşka bir şey bu biz alıp bambaşka
bir yere götüreceğim
aşağı vurmaya başladığı zaman toplumda
nasıl bir Reaksiyon vardı ya bize
çıkmıyor takıyorlar işte Bizi birileri
kontrol etmek için şu anda teknoloji
Elimizde yok yani aşıyla verilecek bir
tip çift Elimizde yok Ama şu var
neuralink var nerolinn ilk kez insanla
makineyi bilgisayarı bir anda
çalıştırabilecek bir teknoloji müthiş
bir şey ve daha ilk adımları atılıyor bu
adımlar daha çok adımlarla olarak
ilerlemeye gittiği zaman bambaşka bir
dünya bambaşka bir insan modelini de
görmüş olacağız
ve bu saygılı Yani bu zincirdeki
unutmayın bunun adı Sanayi 40 içerisinde
anlattığın Her şeyin bir parçası var
Yapay Zeka var robotik var O var bu
vesaire bir şey var her şey var bir tek
bir şey yok İnsan yok çünkü Sanayi 40
zaten insana karşı geliştirilmeye
çalışılan yeni bir sistem ve yıllar
sonra
meraklı hatırlarken kimimizi
hatırlayacak tümünde kötü alacak Çünkü
bu projenin Akım projesi veya onun lanse
etmiş olduğu proje ve gelecekte emin
olun Bunun bedelini insanlık olarak hep
beraber Ödeyeceğiz Şimdi geldik asıl
soruya
ve masumiyetin sona ermiş olduğu ve
seçim yapmamız gereken bir döngü len
geçiyoruz bu filmi hatırlarsınız Size
iki hat uzatılır bir mavidir bir
kırmızıdır
Bu hep böyle bir hap olarak size
verilecek Ya aslında bu hapı yutmaya
başladı hepimiz alıyoruz bunu ufak ufak
dozlarda alıyoruz buna dijitalleşme ve
bunun bir sonraki aşaması olan dijitaliz
bir kelimenin arkasına izim koyarsanız O
bir rejim anlamına gelir Kapitalizm
komünizm neo-liberalizm gibi yeni bir
terminoloji girişiyor burada biz dijital
izliyorsunuz geçen yıl Kandemir evde
otururken
selam
Sevgili Simone Kolin ve Vur Allah
birlikte Bu konu çok düşündük çünkü
annemi döneminde dijitalleşmeye öyle bir
alıştık ki Zoom diyor ya ben pek çok
online program kullanmaya başladık pek
çok program programı şu an tartışır hale
geldik ve ufak Aslında dijitalleşme ile
birlikte dijital İzmir'de bünyemizde
almaya başladı ve bu makale basıldıktan
sonra çok ilginç yorumlar gelmeye
başladı ilk kez dijital izmle
dijitalleşmeye kıyaslayan ve komik
dönemiyle bunu ilişkilendiren ilk
makalelerden biri bu çıktı ve Gerçekten
biz yazarken korktuk tek başımıza ya
başımıza gelecekle ilgili ne gelebilir
ile ilgili Ama şunu söyleyeyim çok güzel
günler insanlığı çok fazla beklemiyor
niye biliyor musunuz bugün Rusya'ya
gidip bir televizyon almak istediğinizde
Rus devletinin yeni çıkarttığı bir kanun
var televizyona sadece rus yazılımlarını
yükleyebilirsiniz diyor bu şu demek o
cihazı ben istediğim zaman kontrol etmek
istiyorum diyor veya Çine gittiğinizde
büyük metropollerde giderken kameralar
sürekli yüzünüzde çekim yapar ve sizi
bir vatandaş numarası ve vatandaş
puanlaması yapar sizi devlet Bir nevi mi
fişler ve buna göre de size bir Kredi
ver veya bugün kullandığınız cep
telefonları için her tarafı her tür
dijital İzninizle dolu veya çok masumane
bir şekilde kullandığımız her uygulaması
e-nabız uygulaması uygulaması bu
uygulaması her yerde parmak izimiz her
yerde retina okuma larımız yani bize bu
masumiyetimizi ait olan hiçbir şey
kalmadı
sosyal medya Öyle bir hale geldi ki
Eskiden sevdiğimiz bir insanın resmini
en sır yerlerinize sakladı konuşup size
göstermezdi o fotoğraf birinde olduğu
zamanda bir problem çıkardı ama bugün
Geldiğimiz noktada herkesin fotoğrafı
sosyal medyanın her tarafında Gezer
Herkes her bulunduğu yerde bir selfie
çeker ve bu hayat ister istemez bizi bir
yere doğru götürecek ve şu maddeleri
okuduğunuzda gelecekte karşımıza çıkacak
olan durumları burada tek tek
görebilirsiniz ekonomi değişecek devlet
yapıları değişecek gençlerin durumu
değişecek yaşam şekillerimiz değişecek
Eğer bu filmi seyrediyor sanız Bu işin
sonunda da in Time yüklenen loading
nedir fazla da geçmiş olacak ve son
kısım insanlık olarak
bu teknolojiyi oldukça iyi bir yere
getirdik acayip işler yaptık öyle böyle
değil soğan erkeği 20 yılda insanlık
tarihinin yaratmış olduğu bilginin yüzde
99'unu Bu Son 20 yılda yarattı Ama şunu
kaçırmaya başladık dünyayı kaçırmaya
başladık Çünkü dünya sizin düşündüğünüz
gibi değişmiyor dünyanın da kendi bir
denklemi var Her modemi güzel bir kuralı
vardır termodinamigi der ki dünyada bir
noktada bir yerde denge bozulduğu zaman
dünya onu başka bir noktada yeniden
denge oluşturur ve insanoğlunun da bir
özelliği vardır toplumlar her zaman en
düşük enerji seviyesinde yaşamak ister
ama biz insanlık olarak nedense burada
duramıyoruz ve sürekli toplumlara bir
entropi yüklemesi yapıyoruz entropi
dünya kaldırmaz bir yere kadar tolera da
sonra kendi dengesini bizim için kurar
onun içinde teknoloji kullanırken bizi
değişmez değiştirmesine mi bu derken bu
konuda dikkat etmemiz lazım Çünkü bir
başka dünyayı şu an Elimizde yok ve bu
dünya ile bu teknoloji birbirine barışık
olarak kullanmamız lazım O kadar çok
teknoloji o kadar çok Gelecekten
bahsettik ama
en son bir buçuk yıldır yaşadığımız şey
teknoloji ile Vesaire de çözemediğimiz
bir virüsün bizi getirdiği bir nokta ve
hepimiz Bugün ne kadarda teknolojik
olursak olalım bir tane bez parçasına
mahkum olarak yaşıyoruz hepinize
teşekkür ediyorum
[Alkış]